more people will soon be eligible to get
the vid19 vaccine rather
in just a matter of weeks nearly every
nevadan will qualify for
shock but starting tomorrow those with
underlying conditions can schedule an
appointment
madison kimbrough joins us live tonight
outside the convention center
with the latest details madison
yes this is major news as vaccine
distribution has been a hot topic of
discussion for months
and how those 16 and older qualify so we
spoke to some high schoolers about what
this means to them
and their future i feel like if more
people were
readily available to the vaccine it
might have gone a little bit quicker and
we could have gotten
more into a sense of normalcy vaccine
distribution increases to those 16 years
old and up
starting monday april 5th this comes
after governor sisselak made the
announcement this past week
also stating that those with
pre-existing conditions
like asthma diabetes cancer and obesity
just to name a few will be eligible
starting tomorrow
18 year old rosemary who just graduated
from high school
in december suffers from asthma and
while she plans on getting her vaccine
this week
she's also urging her friends to make
their appointments now too
i know that i can qualify but i'd rather
have some of my other friends who have
worse asthma than me and i'm really
pushing it on them to get their date
available and i i know that on tuesday
when i go into work i am making an
appointment with my coworker
as for other teens that may have to wait
until the fifth
17 year old student athlete megan says
that getting this vaccine will build up
her confidence
on and off the field i play soccer
football other sports like that
so not only having to always have the
masks but also having that second layer
of protection
having the vaccine on it makes it i
guess a lot more comfortable being able
to go outside hang out with friends
and also going into school is another
really big factor
appointments at the convention center
and cashman center are available
in addition to those sites there will be
a site at csn
in north las vegas that will open
tomorrow and as far as replacing
that option goes that's replacing the
site that was at canyon springs high
school so they're offering first
and second doses that's by appointment
only so look out for that
as for a full list of vaccination sites
you can head to our website
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now